[Musique]
ils sont écoliers collégiens et lycéens
et tous sont lauréats du concours
académique plaisir d'écrire 94 jeunes
récompensés qui ont composé sur une
thématique libre soit sous forme
d'expression écrite de nouvelles ou
encore de poésie les élèves aux
maintenant parler des difficultés qu'ils
ont ce sont les difficultés de la
société
le harcèlement les téléphones portables
les réseaux sociaux voilà tout ce qui
vient s'imbriquer dans la vie dans la
vie du jeune et qu'il n'y a pas
forcément forcément sa place mais on a
aussi beaucoup d'appels vers la vie de
voilà deux choses
enthousiaste et magnifique ou qu'on
maintienne la qualité de la langue
française à travers le verbe travers les
l'écriture à travers la lecture
l'amour est aussi au coeur de
l'inspiration de ses jeunes auteurs yvon
libellé lycéens et il est récompensé par
le premier prix national de la jeune
poésie et réaliser une poésie dont le
titre est la rose bleue où je parle en
fait donc je les écris le jour de la
saint valentin où je parle dans la
matinée par l'époque tout simplement
dans le sens on veut faire passer un
message à une personne peut-être qu'on
aime mais que le message n'a pas été
forcément passé ou n'est pas vraiment
c'est pas un mot précis pourquoi
organisé par l'amopa l'association des
membres de l'ordre des palmes
académiques
le concours plaisir d'écrire révèle
chaque année des jeunes talents et une
jeunesse qui montre son attachement à
toute la richesse de la langue française
[Musique]